guess which one is taken in Africa well
then in that case I'm going to look for
the most affluent ones oh I'm gonna go
with this photo to the right the first
one okay
okay this one right here
yeah that's Africa oh gosh honestly they
both could be um
the left one because according to the
trees and they hide this has to be the
south of United States so like closer to
Florida the one on the right
I think it's the second one
why are you doing this to me no this is
Africa that is correct yeah yeah I think
it's a trick question it looks like
they're all taken in Africa
oh I think the image on the right is
Africa the first one the left one is
Africa I want to say this one got one
yeah I would have never got that